welcome everybody so i want to start
today by spending some time on the
question what is a woman and it might
seem like kind of well you know what is
a banana what is an apple it might seem
kind of out of the blue
but this is a topic that came up last
week during the confirmation hearings
for joe biden's supreme court nominee
katanji brown jackson and we saw
republican senator marsha blackburn ask
among a number of other bad faith
questions
can you give me a definition for a woman
and here's how that went
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not in biology
and after that all took place last week
i appeared on the right-wing daily wire
show hosted by michael knowles and we
could have talked about anything but he
wanted to talk about
what is a woman do i have a definition
for a woman and i explained to him
that this is a bad faith question
that any answer that judge jackson could
have given
would have allowed blackburn to push her
into a corner about this or that
particular situation
and that the reality is
in jackson's role as a supreme court
justice some general definition of a
woman won't really do anything to help
figure out difficult cases since courts
have to adjudicate
specific
and narrow legal issues in particular
situations based on individual
complaints brought to a court but now
that we got that all out of the way i
actually do want to talk about with you
what is the definition because while
most people understood the bad faith
nature of the question there are people
who have reacted and who have emailed me
and have said you know
the definition is so easy
but it's actually not even going by
their simple definitions and i hope that
we can explore
why this is just a bad faith and
unproductive line of discussion and
reasoning now before i get into this i
do want to remind everybody particularly
people who might see this segment hear
this segment and not know me
everything i'm saying here is my best
faith analysis of the situation
and it is with me speaking as an
unfettered defender of trans rights who
understands that this is not a simple
situation and understands the bad faith
nature of why the right keeps saying
give us a definition for woman so ryan
wrote to me
and he explained
david here's why these things are so
tough and meaningless in the abstract
let's say i ask you to define life okay
that's pretty easy right i'll look it up
in the dictionary and let's start with
the dictionary definition why not so a
dictionary definition for life is quote
life
the condition
that distinguishes animals and plants
from inorganic matter
including the capacity for growth
reproduction functional activity and
continual change preceding death
great so now i've bought in
i've picked the definition and that's
what blackburn wanted all the
republicans wanted right
was just pick a definition and give us
that definition but wait a second
are children not life david because they
that was in your definition reproduction
and they can't reproduce
yet
oh that's right that wasn't my
definition what about the elderly who no
longer grow
and who also no longer reproduce oh no
no problem let me tweak the definition
now i've got it i'm gonna get to it okay
the definition is to account for people
who are too young or too old to
reproduce let's have a new a different
definition of life
it's the condition of an organism
that ever had
or will have
that capability of reproduction and
growth then it's life
that's tough that's tough some people
are born without ever having the
capability for reproduction a man with a
sperm disorder kleinfelter syndrome a
woman with certain conditions damn okay
all right well let me walk it back again
so i say
what matters is the species as a whole
if this is a species that as a whole
reproduces even if individual members
for whatever reason might not be able to
then that meets the definition of life
oh no what about mules a mule is what
happens when you breed a female horse
and a male donkey
and they're sterile as a species they
can't reproduce
mules aren't alive now based on my
definition
so you can very quickly see how this
just define it just give us a definition
it's not only bad faith
in theory but it's also really tough in
practice so now let's apply it to the
question of what is a woman
during our interview
michael knowles suggested a few
definitions and one of them check out
the interview if you're interested one
definition he said was it's
anything and anybody that isn't a man
well 1.7 of the population is born
intersexed meaning with both genitals
or with some ambiguity in terms of the
genitalia so if you say if it's if if
they're not a man they're a woman
that definition doesn't account for that
it doesn't work
then nulls said well it's a human that
produces eggs
so a lot of conditions including
hormonal imbalances and thyroid
conditions things in the womb pituitary
tumors that prevent some women from
producing eggs or being able to
reproduce well what about
capability of reproduction through
pregnancy a human with the capability of
reproduction through pregnancy
tons of conditions that inhibit
reproduction and then you've got
post-menopausal women that can't
reproduce but are they not women very
few people would argue that so the point
here is these definitions do not work
for determining
who is a woman since not all biological
women are able to do these things not
all biological women menstruate for
different medical reasons
imagine defining men
simply by their ability to i don't know
impregnate someone or have an erection
so now let's come around to the question
that is actually underlying all of this
for many republicans because
you you have to really understand the
political angle here
they have started to take this
perspective
that anybody can simply assume an
identity
and then tell a court i was
discriminated against on this basis and
ted cruz kind of brought this to the
absurd during the hearings in order to
make an analogy and ted cruz said well
could i as a hispanic man for an hour
say i'm now an asian man
and then sue harvard for anti-asian
discrimination if you can say i'm a
woman now i'm a man why can't i say well
now i'm asian
it sounded kind of nuts
but he said it and here's the clip but
the question
let me ask under the modern leftist
sensibilities if if
i decide right now that that i'm a woman
then
apparently i'm a woman does that mean
that i would have article 3 standing to
challenge a gender-based restriction
senator to the extent that you are
asking me about um
who has the ability to bring lawsuits
based on gender those kinds of issues
are working their way through the courts
and i'm not able to comment on them okay
if if i can
change my gender if i can be a woman and
then an hour later if i decide i'm not a
woman anymore i guess i would lose
article 3 standing
tell me does that same principle apply
to other protected characteristics for
example i'm i'm an hispanic man could
could i decide i was an asian man would
i have the ability to be an asian man
and challenge harvard's discrimination
because i made that decision
senator i'm not able to answer your
question you're asking me about
hypotheticals and um i'm asking you how
you would assess standing if i if i came
in and said i have decided i identify as
an asian man i would assess standing the
way i assess other legal issues which is
to
listen to the arguments made by the
parties consider the relevant precedence
and
constitutional principles involved and
make a determination now of course
we all know that that's silly but why is
it silly
it's because whatever it means to be
asian
ted cruz isn't actually
living life as an asian man which sounds
a little silly when it comes to race but
will then apply it to gender and
importantly society doesn't see ted cruz
as an asian man now i know you can say
but david that's based on stereotypes or
whatever but it gets to something very
important here
when we think about under the law
when i think about like genitals aside
who can bring a lawsuit for gender
discrimination because the whole
idea here is
they they love to say
can a guy put a wig on and then sue and
say i was discriminated against for
being a woman
um
the
reality here
is that when we say who can say i was
discriminated against for being a woman
what i imagine is anyone living
outwardly as a female and seen by
society as a female could bring a
lawsuit for gender discrimination as a
woman now i know it's not perfect
but understand that this is the legal
question i know republicans love to say
you know men with wigs they said man
with a wig hangs out in a bathroom
they're doing all sorts of things and
the point they make is a man with a with
a wig
who doesn't actually live life as a
woman nor is seen by society as a woman
they're gonna have a very hard time
showing in court
that they were discriminated against
for their status as a woman it's going
to be very difficult to show that now
this is not about should we call people
by the pronouns they want to be called
by of course of course that's this is
about the legal question can anybody men
women who ever say i was discriminated
and discriminated against for being a
woman so think about it if i put on a
wig right i wear my current clothes
i have my current voice i go by the name
david
if i do all the things that socially tag
me as male
no court
is going to accept that i was
discriminated against because of the
perception that i was a woman
i could go and do all the things right i
could go to the dmv and say i i want to
be seen as i want to be female now i
want f on my uh
license i could i could do all those
things but
if i sue i'm not going to be able to
show that i was seen as a woman and that
is paramount to proving that you were
discriminated against for gender reasons
now on the other hand if a trans woman
is seen as a woman in whatever situation
they're suing over and they can show
that
why shouldn't they be able to bring such
a lawsuit i mean think about it in many
states you can be fired
for your real or perceived sexual
orientation even if you aren't a gay man
if you're fired because your boss is
homophobic and thought you were gay you
can sue even though you're not actually
a gay man
and similarly
the point here is when they talk about
anybody can just sue and say i was
discriminated against because i'm a
woman well
can you actually show anybody believed
you were a woman in the sense of how
they related to you and their alleged
discrimination so the big point here is
when right wingers ask this stuff number
one it's obviously in bad faith
number two
whatever you say is going to be used
against you but number three
it's actually a lot more complicated
than they pretend these definitions to
be
if we think about it from a legal
standpoint and we talk it through we
actually can make quite a bit of headway
so let me know your thoughts and
hopefully we've touched on what are some
of the
really underlying issues and questions
here uh that that exist
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 percent
off office subscription go to
blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below